so we have three folks jenna sarah and
bill and they're keeping track of their
weight and they're in in particular
they're keeping their track they're
keeping track of their weight over a
month and right over here we have their
weight change over the month so if you
take their ending weight and from that
you subtract their starting weight so
let me just write that that's your end
weight
minus your starting weight that's going
to be your change in weight over that
month
and so we have the change in weights
here so
jenna's change in weight is negative
three pounds which means that she lost
weight
sarah's change in weight is positive two
and a half pounds which means she gained
two and a half pounds
and then bill's weight or change in
weight i should say is positive four
pounds which means he gained four pounds
over the month so given that let's
answer some questions who lost the most
weight who had the largest change in
weight and who had the smallest change
in weight and i encourage you to pause
the video and try to work through it on
your own
well let's just let's just
let's just plot all of these on on a on
a number line here to help us think
through it although you know some of you
might already have an answer here so
jenna's weight change is negative three
pounds so that's jenna
right over there i'll say j for jenna
sarah's
weight change and she had a weight gain
is two and a half pounds
so that's right over there positive two
and a half pounds for sarah and then
finally bill gained four pounds so that
is bill
right over there
now let's answer the question who lost
the most so when we talk about lost
where we care about directions we said
hey who moved who moved most to the left
of zero
well sarah and bill didn't move left to
left to zero at all they gained weight
that's why they're to the right of zero
jenna's the only person who lost
anything so the person who lost the most
is jenna
now who had the largest change and if we
think about the largest change one way
to think about is who is the furthest
away from zero so one way to think about
it is which of these has the largest
absolute value
well the absolute value here the
absolute value of negative three is and
let me be let's see we can just call
this the absolute change
absolute
change
is just going to be the absolute value
absolute value of negative 3 is positive
3.
absolute value
of 2.5
is 2.5
absolute value
let me make this a little bit clearer
absolute value of 4 was just equal to 4.
so who had the largest absolute change
well bill had the largest absolute
change and then second place was
actually jenna she lost weight but she
had a pretty big change she had a three
pound change although it was a three
pound loss bills was a four pound gain
but the largest change is definitely
bill
now who had the least change
well another way to think about it this
is the least absolute change who changed
the least from zero
well if you look at here sarah had the
smallest absolute change
jenna lost weight so the the weight
change of jenna she has negative 3
versus sarah's positive 2.5 but if we
talk about who had the least change from
zero if your weight change was zero that
means you didn't gain or lose weight
from the beginning of the month to the
end of the month so who had the least
change well that's the least absolute
change well we see that right over here
2.5 is less than
three or four
so
the least change is
is sarah and we're done